Jack: Aw, but now I'm with Wade.
Mark: Wooow. (x2)
Wade: Oh, suck it.
Bob: Wow, Jesus.
Bob: Unrelenting.
Mark: Wooow *laughs*
Wade: Deal with it!
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: This prop does not work.
Bob: Wade, did you just turn into your drunk aunt, who's-who's telling you to deal with it, at the Christmas party?
Wade: Deal with it!
Bob: Deal with it!
Wade: You're gonna respect my feet and you're gonna like it- I don't know. What do aunts say?
Jack: Is that a real story?
Mark: What the fuck is that? *laughs*
Wade: What do aunts SAY?
Bob: That was spot on, as far as I know, so...
Mark: Woah.
Bob: That accurately reflects my life experience.
Jack: Oh my god, there's a baby pinned to the wall with a knife over here.
Wade: Oh, I've played this map. This map is HUGE.
Mark: Yeah, it's cool though. Why is this guy dead?
Bob: Hey, there's a fuckin' idiot here in this hallway.
Jack: Aren't you glad I'm not floating?
Wade: Jack, I thought you were on my team?
Mark: No, no. Wait...
Jack: No way.
Bob: Wait, how are Wade and I on the same team?
Mark: Wait, yeah, what happened? What?
Jack: We're on the same teams again!
Wade: How are we on the same team?
Bob: Wade, why did you not change teams?
Bob: That was-
Wade: I DID change teams, but it must've switched right- Okay, we'll switch after this round.
Mark: Oh, I'm not even in the game yet so... Or not- I'm dead. Yeah, I'm dead.
Jack: I'm- No, I wasn't that orange that just ran away.
Wade: Hey, orange! You're too fast!
Jack: No I'm not. I'm just the adequate speed an orange should be. Yeah, this is way too fucking big.
Mark: Woah, this place- This is huuuge. Shit dude.
Bob: Where is things in this place? Oh, for fuck's sake.
Jack: Wee! Weeee!
Bob: Where is you, Wade?
Wade: There's blood!
Bob: Oh, there's some- Well.
Jack: There's blood on the floor!
Jack: Why is this "Underscore Chinese"? Is this a movie reference we're not getting?
Mark: No, it's a Chinese, like Restaurant, or something.
Wade: Alright, I switched teams.
Bob: Will someone-? Someone help me...
Wade: I'm Hunters- Oh wait, someone needs to join Bob's team.
Mark: How do I switch teams?
Jack: How do we switch?
Wade: Press F1 and click "Change Teams".
Mark: So now, I gotta wait another round. I'll cheer you on, Bob, I'll cheer you on in spirit. I'll give you the scoop.
Mark: There's an OUTside?
Jack: Yeah.
Bob: Yeah, there's an outside.
Wade: There's a baby with a knife through its chest, stabbed through a mirror.
Mark: Oh my god.
Bob: How do I look, Mork?
Mark: Wow, actually Bob, that is- I didn't even know you were there.
Mark: Holy shit.
Jack: I don't think sitting around is allowed on this map, Jesus.
Mark: Uh, it is.
Bob: I'm outside, I gave you that hint. I am outside.
Mark: Yeah. He's uh- That fits, amazingly well.
Bob: Also, if I move and anyone is here, I'm so fucked. I'm not a prop that can run around.
Bob: I'm something pretty big.
Mark: *laughs* I mean, you could try.
Bob: I mean, I could TRY it, if you want me to, but...
Jack: That's interesting.
Jack: I'm down.
Bob: I'm not a prop that can run around, and I'm outside.
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: One of you is in the right courtyard, even. I'll give you that, 'cause I think this spot's pretty good.
Wade: We're both TOGETHER!
Bob: Yeah, you're both here, you're both here. I only saw one of you.
Jack: This isn't taking- This isn't damaging me, I thought it was you.
Wade: Are you a sack?
Bob: Nope.
Jack: *giggles*
Bob: Are YOU A SACK?! How does that feel? Ya sack!
Wade: *cries* It doesn't feel good.
Jack: Ya piece of sack!
Bob: Well now you're leaving the courtyard that I'm in.
Jack: Nothing is damaging me. Everything I shoot is good.
Mark: That's 'cause all those aren't actually movable props.
*car horn taunt*
Mark: Woah. *laughs*
Jack: What da fuck?
Bob: I don't know what happened. Someone's just really pissed off or something, I don't know.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: Yeah, you should definitely shoot all that stuff. That's the stuff.
Mark: Yeah.
Wade: Wait a minute. Jack, I think I found-
Bob: NO! NO! Wait, hang on, let's talk about this!
Mark: Wait!
Wade: Noooo!
Jack: What is he? What was he?
Bob: AH!
Bob: AH! AH! AH! Dick. You dick.
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: He was a metal pipe, sitting on the side of the wood.
Mark: How did you even find that?
Bob: It was 2 v 1, man! Fucking just shoot immediately.
Wade: Yeah, we gotta let Mark get in, man.
Jack: Sure. Yeah. Let's blame that. *laughs*
Bob: Wade, back to his old antics of shooting everything that moves.
Mark: Wow, yeah.
Wade: You ran away! I was just gonna show Jack where you were.
Bob: I thought we were in a good place last time. We were playing with the penis. Everyone was having a good time.
Jack: Oh, that's not the way to go.
Wade: You threw my penis away, Bob. Don't think I forgot that.
Bob: Well, I was trying to keep my eyes in the corner, so I didn't cheat and see Mark getting into his masterful position.
Mark: It was amazing. You guys all agreed. You can say whatever you want, you liked it, you liked my penis.
Bob: It's pretty much the- I mean, I liked looking at it.
Bob: I don't know how I feel about it, professionally, as a- Hey.
Jack: *laughs* I wasn't gonna look directly at it, but...
Bob: What's up? What's up, friend? What's up, friend extinguisher? Wait, what the fuck? Where'd you go?
Wade: What's up, my Cranky Crew?
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: "Friend extinguisher".
Mark: Hey, Bob, I'm coming behind you, wait.
Wade: Oh. Hey!
Wade: How's it going? See you later!
Mark: Were you waiting for something there, Wade?
Wade: Yeah, I was waiting for Bob.
Bob: Was Wade fire extinguishing out here?
Mark: Yeah, he was just looking at you, and he went back- Oh nope, he's right there.
Wade: Oh. I'm gonna find Jack. Alright, alright. Let's go find Jack.
Mark: Hello. Hi. I'm following him.
Bob: Where's he at?
Mark: Yeah okay, alright, okay. Lead me to Jack, and you will be handsomely rewarded. Mmm!
Bob: Oh okay, I found you guys. Come on, come on there, extinguishey!
Mark: With gold and doubloons! Mmmm!
Wade: *pshh* He's this way!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: It's not quite the same as a dick, but I'll take it.
Wade: *pshh* I think he might be... not here.
Mark: *sigh*
Jack: Yeah, leave me alone, go away, I don't want any of your shit.
Wade: *pshhh* That way, this way!
Mark: Alright, alright.
Wade: I feel it. Oh! There's 2 brooms here! And 2 buckets. No, that's right.
Mark: Hmm...
Wade: There's a knife on these stairs.
Mark: Ah, Jack is a bottle? That's just profiling!
Wade: *pshh* He's on this floor.
Jack: Uhh, how dare you? My dad was a bottle.
Bob: I don't think, uh...
Mark: Mmm...
Bob: Uhh, my dad invented bottles, so...
Jack: Oh, no, my dad "loved" the bottle, so no, never mind.
Wade: *pshhh*
Jack: Are you, like, sniffing? Or fucking spraying a hose? What are you doing?
Mark: Yeah. I can't tell what you're doing.
Bob: Listen, hey, fire extinguisher.
Bob: Fucking come here, and listen to me. You see this? You see where this is right now?
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Ohh, you're a fire extinguisher. Okay.
Wade: Wait, what are you doing with that knife? Don't cut my cord!
Bob: You see what I'm about to cut off?
Wade: No! I need-
Mark: Oh, he's crazy, man. He'll do it!
Wade: OW!
Mark: He'll cut your hose!
Bob: I'll fucking do it, man.
Wade: Don't! Please! All I have is my hose!
Bob: I'll fucking cut your hose clean off.
Mark: Dude, he's out of his mind!
Jack: Where even ARE you guys?
Bob: Tell us where he is! You tell us where he fucking is!
Mark: Just tell him! Tell him, man!
Wade: What is a man-stinguisher? He's this way, okay?
Bob: Alright, I believe you.
Mark: I think you went a little to hard on him, Bobbo.
Jack: I don't even know where the fuck you guys are. Haven't seen you at all.
Bob: I think he's a little too- Wait, where the fuck did he-? Oh, there you are.
Mark: This place is like-
Bob: Are you outside or inside, Jack? This is fucking huge.
Jack: I'm outside, and I can't get inside.
Mark: Ohh, you're that big, huh? Oh okay.
Wade: Ohh.
Bob: Oh, interesting.
Bob: He's huge.
Wade: *pshh* Nope.
Mark: God, for some reason, this map just killed my framerates. Are you guys getting the same thing?
Jack: Yeah, every now and then, I just get stuttered.
Mark: It's like "Bwah, too much Chinese!"
Wade: Oh my goodness, um...
Wade: There's a lot of fish down here.
Mark: Ahh, are you thinking what we're thinking?
Wade: Yeah, there's something "fishy" going on.
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: And just Bob goes down there, starts slapping every fish like "Hey! Jack! Hey!"
Jack: *laughs*
Wade: Why isn't there water?
Bob: Oh hey.
Jack: Hi. *laughs*
Bob: What's up, buddy? That's a pretty good spot.
Mark: *laughs* Wait, where is he?
Mark: Where is he?
Bob: I see-
Jack: I didn't want to be too cheeky.
Jack: Wait, come to where I was.
Bob: I see you were trying to use my metal pole tactics. It's pretty good, right?
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: Were you the same metal pole?
Bob: Yeah, I was that metal pole.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: I was over here. How obvious would I have been, like right next to this pole?
Bob: Oh, that's nice, that's really nice.
Mark: Oh, that would've been good. That would've been good.
Wade: That would've been- Yeah, that's nice.
Jack: Double- The Double Pole?
Mark: Yeah.
Bob: The only thing that gives you away is your shadow- Pizza Slice shadow thing.
Jack: You do realize Wade just ran away, right?
Bob: That's fine.
Mark: Yeah, that's fine. He did his job.
Bob: Yeah.
Jack: Did he? 'Cause he didn't find me. Bob found me.
Bob: I mean, it's whatever.
Mark: *laughs* Oh god!
Wade: I lead him to the right area...
Jack: I can't get in!
Bob: Can I break the glass for you?
Jack: I'm a room divider! Ow!
Bob: Wait, sorry, can you like, jump? Can you jump up on these benches, maybe? And then try and like, jump across and get on the roof?
*BOOM*
Mark: Well- SORRY! Sorry! I did not mean for that! Sorry!
Bob: Holy shit, dude! Holy fuck, man!
Jack: Ow! Dude!
Jack: I- I see- I see what it is.
Bob: You just murdered a friend in cold blood.
Mark: I'm sorry! I did- It was an accident.
Mark: The button is really close to the not shoot button.
Bob: *sigh*
Mark: I'm sorry.
Bob: I can't walk slowly, so I'm just gonna have to sprint in short bursts away from you.
Mark: Okay. Bob, come on. Don't be like this, Bob. Bob! Bob!
Jack: *laughs* Sad music.
Wade: I think I'm in a good spot, Jack.
Bob: *hums sad music*
Wade: Hey, don't shoot that gong, that's way too close.
Mark: I was hoping it was gonna be a dramatic moment, with the gong.
Bob: *keeps humming*
Wade: Hey. Hey there.
Jack: *blows glass bottle*
Mark: *sigh*
Bob: Oh.
Jack: A gong for victory. *blows*
*BOOM*
Wade: OW!
Mark: Bob- Oh.
Mark: I was about to kill myself, Bob, in honor.
*all laugh*
Bob: You know what? I found Wade, and suddenly I feel better about everything, so it's fine.
Jack: Conduct horrible jokes.
Wade: I mean I WAS a toilet in a hallway. It wasn't exactly hard to find me.
Bob: No, I found you, Wade. Don't steal this from me. I'm so up to this bullshit.
Jack: Okay, on the prowl.
Jack: Here we go.
Bob: Alright, I'm inside, and I look kind of like a dick.
Bob: Give you a hint right off the bat, 'cause I wanna spice shit up a little.
Jack: Well yeah, but what does your prop look like?
Bob: *fake laugh*
Wade: Ohh! Shits fired- Shots fired!
Mark: Bob, I'm sorry.
Jack: "Shit fired?"
Bob: *laughs* "Shit fired!"
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: "Shit fired!" *laughs*
Bob: Shit- Jack slinging some shit my way! *laughs*
Jack: You made me do that, like weird snort exhale, and it hurt my neck.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: I was like, mid-breath. Ugh.
Wade: What the hell?
Jack: I need a lozenge.
Bob: Okay, at least you didn't have to make the dick censor noise.
Wade: I got a suicide bomb?!
Mark: What?
Bob: What?
Wade: *screams*
Jack: Oh, Jesus Christ!
Jack: I just walked in, and that went off!
Bob: Oh my god! Jeez.
Mark: What the fuck was that?
Wade: I found a ball that gave me a suicide bomb.
Jack: Ohhh, wait, are you a big prop?
Wade: Oh my god, that was horrifying.
Jack: You said you kinda looked like a dick. Are you, like bigish?
Bob: I'm like mediumly big, yeah.
Jack: Yeah, I think I know what you are. Are you like a propane tank?
Bob: Nah-uh. No.
Jack: Oh, 'cause they kinda look like dicks.
Wade: Yeah, they definitely are.
Mark: I don't-
Bob: I don't look- I look like a dick from like, most- from the right angles.
Mark: Okay, I don't know-
Bob: I'm also inside, I'll give you inside, for me. I'm inside.
Mark: I don't know what the fuck I am.
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: I think I'm a bucket of shit, with a stick in it.
Bob: Oh, we're the same thing!
Mark: Oh, you're that thing?
Bob: Yeah, it looks like a dick, right?
Mark: I mean, kinda, yeah.
Wade: Oh, hey, I found you.
Bob: NO! Not like this!
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: What- Hey, don't turn into a paper ball!
Bob: I'm not running! (x3)
Bob: I'm right here. Here, I'll become something big. Can I become that? There I go. Hello.
Jack: *laughs* The worst.
Wade: Alright, help me find the Mark dick bucket.
Bob: Alright, I'm gonna use my newspaper sense. *fffff*
Mark: Yeah, hang on. I'm trying to find you guys. How the fuck do I get in?
Jack: Yeah, I can't fuckin'-
Bob: *ffffff*
Jack: Shut UP!
Bob: Is that what newspaper sounds like? *ffff*
Jack: No! It's like you're breathing into the mic.
Mark: Oh wait, there you guys are. Turn around. Turn around. Wait. No, I'm here.
Wade: Oh hey. Jack, I found him!
Mark: What the fuck am I?
Bob: Yeah, you're like a mop bucket
Jack: I don't even know where you are!
Mark: No, it's-
Wade: Eww! I never looked inside them.
Wade: It's like vomit!
Mark: Yeah! I'm full of shit, guys!
Bob: Oh wait, hang on. I'm not running, Wade, I'm just hopping up here.
Jack: *laughs* Where the fuck are you guys?
Bob: Can you become all of this stuff? Look at all these things. We're in the kitchen, bro.
Wade: I don't know. Jack, we're in the kitchen.
Jack: Oh, okay. I'm on my way.
Mark: Oh.
Bob: Oh no. Oh hey, I'm bananas. Awh, I'm stuck!
Bob: Oh well. I guess I'm not getting away. Wade, can you nudge me a little bit?
Wade: They're bananas and beans.
Bob: Yeah, Mark, yeah, get on there.
Mark: I'm trying.
Wade: I don't know what you're-
Wade: Woah!
Mark: I'mma nudge you. Woah, shit.
Bob: There we go!
Mark: No, I'm not running away, Wade. I'm not running away. I swear.
Wade: Yeah, they're not running away. They're just leaving.
Mark: No, I'm back on the thing.
Bob: I'm not running anywhere, Wade.
Jack: Control them!
Bob: Ah, you bitch.
Jack: Ah, there you go. Hello.
Wade: I don't know where Mark went. Mark still might be in here.
Mark: *laughs*
Mark: I said I wasn't running away!
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: Well yeah, but I don't know what you are, I was too busy following Bob.
Bob: Mark, don't tell him. Don't tell him. *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Wade, did you just get made a fool of, when I wasn't here?
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: I killed Bob as he ran away. Mark's probably one of these. Is he the fish under the beans? No.
Mark: *laughs* I didn't GO anywhere!
Wade: He is the beans. Okay.
Jack: He was the fuckin' beans.
Bob: He was the huge fuckin' beans! The same thing he was before!
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: There were 2 trays- Well I didn't know! You were both jumping around! I killed your ass, didn't I?!
Mark: *laughs* Yeah, you did.
Bob: Oh, you feel like a big man, with your gun, Wade?
Jack: See, rewind back to the start of the round when I was sad that I was with Wade.
Jack: Now you know why.
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *laughs*
Wade: How many kills did you have last round, Jack? That's right, a big fat 0!
Bob: That is true, sorta gotcha there.
Mark: Yeah, gotta admit, yeah.
Jack: Got- Got me.
Wade: Yeah, I guess we can. I'll follow you.
Bob: Oh god, I'm stuck in the- I'm fucking stuck in the ceiling, are you fucking kidding me?
Jack: Hep! Okay.
Mark: Wait, what?
Jack: Okay, I gotta climb on that.
Wade: Oh, I got- I got up here!
Jack: Yeah, cool, me too.
Bob: Mark, can you- Can you help me?
Mark: Where are you?
Bob: I'm in one of the blue tunnels, the like, back tunnels. I'm like, stuck.
Mark: Yeah, okay. Oh my god!
Mark: Guys! We got a Ghost Problem!
Bob: *laughs* OooooHHHHHhhh!
Bob:  OooOOOooohHhh
Jack: I wanna see the ghost, but I can't, so...
Mark: Oh noooo! Wait. I have no idea how to help you, cause-
Bob: Oh, you can't push me? Can you pick anything up, and like, hit me with props or something?
Mark: Uh, maybe. *grunts*
Wade: There you go. Oh no!
Jack: Oh fuck.
Jack: Got it, got it.
Mark: Oh Jesus, this ghost is really stuck!
Bob: God, I'm really stuck in here, huh?
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: Jesus- BEGONE, DEMON! Be-fucking-GONE!
Wade: I think you look great. You look great there.
Jack: Yeah, you're good.
Bob: *laughs*
Jack: *fpta-fpta-fpta-fpta*
Mark: Jesus, ghost! Just FUCK OFF!
Bob: Just really wail on me. You know what, Mark?
Bob: You know what, Mark?
Mark: Yeah what?
Bob: You know, sometimes, you just gotta let the ones that you love go, okay?
Mark: No! I can't be here for this again!
Bob: Sometimes you just gotta let me go, Mark.
Mark: Bob, no!
Wade: They're just doing their own thing over there, okay.
Jack: I wanna know what's happening.
Mark: Bob- NOOO!
Bob: Are you ready, Mark? I'm gonna end it now.
Mark: NOO! Bob, please no!
Jack: Oh hey.
Wade: Oh.
Bob: It's gonna be up to you, okay? I'm leaving everything to you.
Mark: NOO! I can't take that level of stress.
Bob: I love you, Mark.
Mark: Awh, Bob...
Mark: I have strong feelings for you, too. *crusty grunt*
Jack: Awh, he didn't reciprocate! He killed me, he didn't reciprocate your love.
Bob: *giggles*
Bob: Wait, you killed Jack?
Mark: *laughs* I didn't- Who did I kill?
Jack: I think we're finding out all sorts of things about our "friend" Markiplier.
Mark: I didn't kill you.
Bob: Who killed Jack?
Jack: You just ran by both of us, so.
Mark: What? Well then you're not dead. What?
Bob: Oh, yeah, that's weird.
Wade: I don't know who said someone was dead.
Jack: What are you talking about?
Bob: You just said "he killed me."
Mark: You just said I killed you.
Wade: No.
Wade: You ran by us a while ago.
Jack: "Last round." "Last time."
Mark: Oh, "Last round," okay. I got you, okay, alright.
Wade: Where'd you go, Mark?
Bob: Where'd you guys-? Barrels?
Mark: Eenie meanie, miney mohney
Jack: Oh. I didn't even realize that I'm stuck, so good job, me.
Bob: Mark, I think they're back out that door, alley that you ran in here.
Mark: Alright so, they're not here...
Bob: Oh wait...
Jack: *laughs* You looked right at us, "They're not here."
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: *laughs*
Bob: Does THIS belong here, Mark?
Mark: I don't know. They're goofin' me. Ah, shit.
Bob: Were you guys really in the hallway where we were stuck-? Oh, one of 'em's just a box that just ran away, now one of 'em's a barrel in the hallway, Mark.
Mark: *laughs*
Jack: Uh, Bob? A little fuckin' hush-quiet would be nice.
Wade: Mark, where are you going? Come back!
Mark: Hang on, wait. Bob, THIS is why I couldn't take this pressure!
Bob: Jack's in the kitchen, Mark. Jack's in the kitchen.
Mark: With Dinah? That bastard! Wait.
Bob: Nah, just regular kitchen.
Mark: Okay, alright then. So someone, somewhere, is out here.
Jack: *laughs*
Wade: I'll just wait here then.
Bob: I think- Oh! He's going back out the door. He's a teapot! Going back out the door, now he's in that blue hallway!
Mark: Eaahhh!
Mark: I'm on the WAAAY!
Wade: Hey Mark. No, wrong way, Mark. He went the other way.
Bob: Now he's a box! He's- No, Mark, hallway!
Mark: Oh shit. I'm on the WAAAY!
Jack: I'm not anything, shut up.
Wade: Alright, see ya!
Bob: Now he's a fucking tiny little piece of paper, now he's a pipe.
Mark: You're dicking with MEEEE! Fuck! Wait.
Wade: See ya, Mark! Hey! See ya.
Bob: What the fuck IS that? Eh, whatever.
Mark: What? Is that you? No. GodDAMMIT!
Wade: Hey- Ope, see ya.
Mark: *exhale* Alright, okay.
Wade: Hi, Mark.
Bob: I'm just gonna follow Mark around.
Jack: I fucked myself.
Jack: I know I fucked real hard, oh I fucked good, dude.
Wade: Oh, see ya, Mark! Oh hey, how's it going?
Bob: Wade, are you that thing right there that are touching?
Mark: Oh, oh.
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: Mark, blue hallway, blue hallway, go!
Mark: Blue hallway, I'm on it! I'm on the WAAAY!
Bob: He ran down here.
Mark: Uh-huh.
Bob: And he ran down this way.
Mark: Uh?
Bob: And he became some shit.
Mark: Is he this? No! This one? No.
Bob: Check those- No, no, he's fine.
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: No, no. Mark...
Mark: No?
Wade: Nice work, Jack.
Jack: *sigh* I said "blue hallway"!
Mark: I was THERE! WHERE?! WHAT?!
Wade: Yes you were. Hey! See ya!
Jack: Exactly! And you left! Oh MY GOD!
Bob: I don't understand what you are either, actually.
Jack: Thanks!
Mark: AHH! What the fuck?!
Bob: That didn't look-
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: WOAH! *laughs*
Jack: Ahhhhm... Ooop!
Jack: Ah, well...
Mark: Jesus. *laughs* Just from my perspective, I thought you just like, exploded!
Wade: *laughs*
Jack: Well, it looked like I did!
Bob: *laughs*
Mark: Ahh, no...
Wade: Live! *laughs*
Jack: YES! YES!
Mark: Holy shit- OH NO! Ah! You had too much health! Oh nooo!
Jack: -yourself.
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: We had a good round that time.
Jack: You walked by us, like so many times.
Mark: I know, it's just, I don't work well under pressure.
Wade: It looked like you came around the corner, Jack was a box, I was the fish right there. You looked right at both of us, you're like, "Well, not here!"
Wade: You turned around and left! *laughs*
Mark: *laughs* I didn't see anything out of the ordinary.
Jack: To his defense, he's very dumb.
Bob: I mean, Wade, you were a dark thing in a dark corner. You weren't exactly-
Jack: Yeah.
Wade: Yeah, for me, it looked like I was really bright on my screen.
Mark: Hagh! Hagh! Don't come after me!
Jack: Oh hey. *laughs* No, no! Dude, it's okay!
Mark: Hagh! Heh! Ha! HA! Hahaha!
Jack: Wait, can I close these doors? Uh, dude, it's okay, we're all friends here. PUT! The knife down!
Mark: Hah haah! Haaah!
Jack: Put yourself down. Wade, I'm scared, I'm running away, Wade. I can't handle the situation.
Wade: Oh. Alright, I'm trained in melee combat.
Mark: Alright, okay. *fighting music*
Mark: *fighting music*
Jack: *fighting music*
Mark: Ah, fuck!
Jack: *trills* I didn't even get to the good part!
Wade: *laughs*
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: I'm sorry, he jumped at me, I had to defend myself!
Bob: God fuckin'- *grunts*
Jack: Can I be this baby?
Bob: Wait, I have a better idea.
Jack: Bob, you okay?
Bob: Nah, I'm fine, I'm just "Ech"ing a little.
Wade: Wait, the baby? Is that the one that's knifed to the mirror?
Jack: Yeah.
Mark: Bob, that is the best spot.
Bob: Right? It seems pretty good.
Mark: That is an amazing spot.
Jack: Okay, gotta sniff 'em out.
Wade: Man, if only that crazy knife stabber was still alive, we could use him to help.
Jack: Yeah, if only you didn't fuckin' kill him.
Mark: Hey. Yeah, you killed me.
Mark: What are you talking about?
Wade: He JUMPED at me! He was a knife!
Mark: Alright...
Wade: It was self-defense!
Jack: I don't know man, you got a lot of armor on.
Bob: Oh my god, Mark, where-? Okay, never mind. I thought I had broken stuff, but it's fine.
Mark: Yeah, you're- you're- nah- yeah.
Bob: How am I lookin' now?
Mark: *exhale* Not as good as I thought you were. I mean, I look to you for inspiration, and I'm just- I'm feeling a little empty inside.
Jack: *laughs*
Bob: You know what? Why don't you just eat some shit? How 'bout that?
Bob: HAh!
Mark: Wait, what's going on behind that st- behind that thing?
Jack: Are you "HAh"ing, 'cause I was near?
Bob: No.
Mark: Are you seeing what I'm seeing?
Bob: Yeah, what the hell? Can I go in there? Kinda.
Mark: Just a portal into another world?
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: What?
Bob: Oh!
Jack: Can you get out to the, like gazebo out the back? 'Cause I was trying that.
Bob: I'm not outside, don't worry.
Mark: Oh, I see what you're trying to do. Ahh.
Mark: That's gonna be-
Bob: Yeah, right? AH! Oh god! I fell into the portal to the other world!
Mark: *laughs*
Bob: *laughs* Hang on. *laughs*
Jack: He's in the toilet! That's the portal to another world!
Wade: That IS the portal to a world that we don't wanna be in.
Bob: WHAT?! Really?
Mark: *laughs*
Wade: What?
Jack: What are you doing? Where are you?
Bob: I was right next to someone.
Mark: Awh, so close! Wow.
Bob: Wow! Am I invisible?